[Music]
on this Friday night clear for takeoff
the 11th Hour deal keeping WestJet and
swoop pilots in the air and the mess
Left Behind from all those canceled
flights it's never easy to put Humpty
Dumpty back together again
frayed nerves in Alberta with more homes
threatened served for doing everything
they can to protect it the province's
latest precautions to prevent new
wildfires the escalating feud between
Mickey Mouse and Florida's governor we
will fight the woke the potential
political consequences
and deciphering a different kind of sign
language it's a little weird it's a
little weird the app steering Montreal
drivers out of trouble
[Music]
global national with para Nasser
good evening and thank you for joining
us some welcome news for travelers
heading into this long weekend WestJet
and its Pilots reached eight late night
tentative agreement something that
seemed unlikely 24 hours ago and though
it stopped full-blown travel turmoil for
customers many are still not as relaxed
as they'd like to be this Friday this
man trying to get home to BC sums up the
experience
it's a trip from Hell there were many
many thousands of people uh this has
screwed up people's lives big time you
know it was just a long super 20 hour
day uh that's not what I signed up for
now what he signed up for but what he
and so many others received as Mike
drolet reports in our top story tonight
it could be days before westjet's
flights are back on schedule
with negotiations Running on Fumes
WestJet landed a deal with its Pilots
hello today Westchester and IPA the
union representing WestJet and Sewer
Pilots reached in tentative agreement on
our second collective bargaining
contract but not before canceling almost
a third of its Friday flights as a
precaution creating anxiety and travel
Chaos on a long weekend very frustrating
all night we were checking the online
flight Council never know what was going
on now we come here to the airport our
flight has been canceled the more than
1800 Pilots for WestJet and its
subsidiary swoop had been negotiating
for nine months and ultimately secured
400 million dollars in new money over
the next four years as well as the
option of a pension yeah I gotta say you
know there were some UPS some downs but
I I think it ended on a pretty good note
on a good note is all about perspective
analysts say WestJet which owns 28
percent of Canada's domestic Market
could not have survived a lengthy strike
and even a few days could have cost the
company tens of millions well they
dodged a bullet for sure even a day or
two days or three days is an incredible
uh costly experience for them but that's
a little consolation for this family
stuck in Vancouver after traveling from
the Philippines my uh travel agency
didn't told me nothing I just pawned him
in arrived here they said our flight is
already concealed WestJet certainly has
its work cut out for them planes and
Pilots are out of position cleaning it
all up could take until the middle of
next week it's never easy to put Humpty
Dumpty back together again so they now
in front of them have a bunch of pieces
that don't fit together that they have
to reassemble so that they've got that
jigsaw puzzle back together one of the
biggest pieces will take time to fix its
reputation I would probably not use
WestJet again unless I really had to I
will look elsewhere from now on
microwave Global News Toronto
and leaders Summit kicked off today in
Japan the world's seven richest
democracies including Canada announced
new sanctions on Russia as well as more
funding to protect against nuclear
weapons in a symbolic gesture the group
paid respect to victims of the 1945
Atomic bombing of Hiroshima as Mackenzie
gray reports nuclear disarmament and the
war in Ukraine are expected to dominate
the agenda throughout the weekend
a stark reminder of the catastrophic
causes of War
world leaders laying wreaths at
hiroshima's peace Park in the shadow of
the only building to survive the first
atomic blast particularly touching
because it's in
you but also a place of tremendous
significance as a warning to us all
Japan is helping use the memory of the
140 000 people who died from the
explosion to promote arms control and to
send a message to Vladimir Putin don't
use a nuclear weapon in Ukraine a
nuclear weapons and proliferation is not
just an abstract
threat it's a very uh real one the Prime
Minister also focused on Russia Canada
is announcing 70 more than 70 new
sanctions on entities and individuals
complicit in the military actions
against Ukraine but also people who are
complicit in the human rights violations
the G7 countries saying they'll support
Ukraine for as long as it takes as they
all announce additional sanctions
what Vladimir zielinski really wants is
weapons the Ukrainian president asking
for air defense systems and long-range
missiles a well-received request
object Ukraine what they need more
weapons more ammunition and faster
zielinski was scheduled to join the G7
virtually but in the last second twist
he'll now fly to Hiroshima to
participate in person where he'll likely
asked G7 guests like India and Brazil
who've been reluctant to support Keith
for raid and request Western governments
send them fighter jets they're kind of
next on the list after tanks and Rockets
and all kinds of systems have been
provided uh so I think it's very highly
likely that the U.S would provide
approval supporting Ukraine is likely
the easy part of the summit what the
leaders Now set to tackle how to handle
China and while there's an agreement
around the table on the threat that
Beijing poses there isn't consensus on
how to address it
Kenzie gray Global News Hiroshima Japan
and before heading to Japan zelinski
made a surprise stop in Saudi Arabia he
addressed leaders at the Arab League
Summit with a personal appeal to broaden
support for Ukraine Beyond Western
allies Russia has stepped up long-range
attacks this month overnight another
wave of new strikes with troops setting
fire to several buildings in zelinski's
Hometown Crystal gemancing Reports on
Ukraine's desperate plea for more help
a noble call to all of you to help
protect our people including Ukrainian
Muslim Community a tailored message to
the Arab League a mix of leaders who has
oil producing Nations have ties with
Russia but have supported Ukraine at the
U.N General Assembly
the prime minister of Iraq was
personally invited to visit Ukraine by
Vladimir zielinski in February Iraq
voted in favor of a U.N General Assembly
motion calling on Russia to end the war
a year earlier it abstained Ukraine's
bid for new friends comes as the Russian
defense minister reportedly visited a
command post on russian-controlled
Ukrainian territory
the Russian Federation released these
images saying the medal ceremony took
place in zaverizia shot indoors in a
bunker-like setting Global News is not
able to confirm the location nor the
date of the video
Ukraine claims it is making progress
south and north of bakmut reclaiming
land meter by meter Russian forces are
mostly confined to the city over which
it has near total control Ukraine
estimates the entire front line of the
war stretches over 3 700 kilometers
explaining why zelenski is on an
in-person tour for support and weapons
we have less air power we do not possess
numerous killer drones that Iran
supplies to Russia we do not have that
much artillery but
we do stay strong
day 450 of the full invasion brings more
Russian missile strikes the air defense
system is helping to keep those in the
capital safer but zielinski says more
defensive weapons are needed Crystal
commencing Global News London
and another notable guest at the Arab
League Summit Syrian president Bashar
al-assad who was invited for the first
time in 13 years Assad received a warm
welcome from Arab leaders after being
shunned because of his brutal Crackdown
on civilians in a civil war that killed
more than 300 000 people in 2011 Syria
was suspended from the league and
isolated by most of the region Saudi
Arabia which had supported groups
fighting Assad's rule slowly warmed up
to him when he secured his grip on power
that's despite objections from the west
and many syrians who see him as a war
criminal in his speech Assad called The
Summit a historic opportunity to address
crises in the region without foreign
interference more than ten thousand
people are still out of their homes in
Alberta and Beyond tonight as nearly 100
wildfires burn but there is hope on the
horizon as more crews from the Yukon and
the United States are expected to arrive
in the coming days to help the fight as
Nathan Garcia reports residents are
trying to make the best out of a bad
situation
this Fox Creek Family finding moments of
normalcy as they spend a second week out
of their home waiting on more word with
how everything is going there First
Responders have been keeping us updated
he's among hundreds still in nearby
White Court who are trying to stay
positive as flames get closer to their
homes nervous about our house our job
on Thursday officials said shifting fire
Behavior led to the closure of this
section of Highway 43.
few hours before the Flames jumped the
highway now despite this highway closure
some drivers chose to stay back and wait
it out
with few options for alternate routes
it's understandable there's fires
everywhere we're going to an oilfield
camp that needs power so we're have
parts to fix everything and we're just
trying to get up there so they have
power Jacqueline Lorac is among
thousands displaced by a wildfire near
Hay River Northwest Territories she's
trying to get to her family members in
Grand Prairie the fires took out my town
and the reserve they all had to migrate
a bit more south but South just as
fire infested as the north so we're all
just kind of stuck together the
accessibility for a lot of our Nations
they're especially the northern ones
that are more isolated so that's a
unique need there not like I said our
commanders are in communication daily
with the chief and Council to address
those concerns see a helicopter with a
bucket an RCMP escorted look at this
First Nations Community about 100
kilometers east of Grand Prairie shows
the fire activity is intense
on Friday Sturgeon Lake Cree Nation
extended its state of emergency and says
more support may be needed from the
federal and provincial governments Chief
Sheldon sunshine has been making daily
visits and says all agencies are working
hard to save the remaining homes we made
the quick call with Council he said
let's evacuate everybody
and with extreme fire risk expected over
the long weekend Alberta's government
has closed provincial parks to try and
reduce the risk of more wildfires
starting
Global News
there appears to be some progress in
negotiations about the stellantis
electric vehicle battery plant in
Windsor Ontario now Ontario Premier Doug
Ford is making this promise
and I will confirm we're putting more
money uh on the table there uh this is
all about saving jobs and giving people
the quality of life they deserve in
Southwestern Ontario
Ford did not confirm an amount earlier
this week's delantis stopped
construction over concerns the federal
government has not delivered what was
agreed to prime minister Justin Trudeau
and Premier Ford had originally pledged
up to a billion dollars for the battery
plant the five billion dollar facility
is one of the biggest Automotive
investments in Canadian history
Princess Anne is in Atlanta Canada to
Mark the 175th anniversary of the
country's oldest Regiment of which she
is the colonel in Chief
the sister of King Charles arrived in
Moncton where she laid a wreath at the
RCMP Memorial she's here until Sunday
and will meet with regiment members past
and present attend a concert parade and
a Gala dinner
dramatic rescues in Italy coming up the
efforts to save people trapped by flood
waters
thank you
rescue operations are underway in
Northern Italy for people Stranded by
devastating floods around 20 000 people
have been displaced and at least 14
people have died extreme rain over the
past week triggered up to 300 landslides
and caused more than 20 rivers to
overflow and the flooding in Italy is
yet another example of extreme weather
linked to climate change in this country
we're seeing an early and aggressive
start to the Wildfire season in western
Canada and along with it Skies filled
with smoke as Jamie Dahl explains there
are concerns more people will face
health challenges as our planet's
temperatures shift
you feel it especially after a long
season you can feel it in your lungs you
can feel it in your body it takes a
while to clear it out two decades he
spent fighting on the front lines of
North America's largest wildfires 20
years breathing in the smoke you have to
sacrifice a lot being in that smoke
every day is is not healthy you're also
working 12 to 15 hour days you're
working up to 24 days in a row it takes
a grind on your body takes a ground in
your relationships and your mental
health as well ultimately it was a
health decision that led Harold Larson
to hang up his hat I have some friends
that had some long-term impacts and you
know some friends that aren't with us
today and as a seasonal firefighter in
Alberta you don't get any pension or any
benefits or any sick days so that's one
of the big reasons why I don't work
there anymore because I needed to look
into the future and if I did get sick I
needed to have a job where I could take
care of myself
burn out of
converter according to a World Health
Organization report more than 20 percent
of all cardiovascular deaths are caused
by air pollution and there is a growing
fear as global temperatures rise those
numbers will too we do know that climate
is making extreme weather worse and it's
making other things that affect our
health worse too like air pollution heat
waves all of those things are
contributing to a substantial number of
increased deaths and illnesses that
could be preventable it comes as no
surprise to some what we thought would
happen is now happening climate change
is here and it's affecting us and it
will affect our physical and mental
health for decades to come Sanford says
not only are people at higher risk for
disease and heat exhaustion but
evacuations loss of homes and Smoky
Skies take a toll on people's emotional
well-being something Harold Larson
understands clearly His Thoughts with
those still putting out the fires they
might have a long road ahead of them but
it will eventually end but just make
sure you're keeping yourself safe and do
your best to stay healthy as you can JB
dog Global News
Disney vs DeSantis ahead the Florida
Feud pitting business against politics
Disney has backed out of its plans to
build a one billion dollar corporate
campus in Florida it's the latest
Outburst in a long-running feud between
the corporation and the state's
Republican Governor as Jackson prosco
reports Disney's decision could do real
damage to the governor's brand at a
crucial time
without naming Florida's governor Disney
dropped a bombshell as it pulled the
plug on a one billion dollar corporate
campus near Orlando scrubbing plans to
relocate 2 000 high-paying jobs to the
state it's a missed opportunity for us
officially Disney blamed changing
business conditions but there was no
missing the message the move seemed time
to strike at the presidential Ambitions
of Republican Governor Ron DeSantis
who's set to launch his bid for the
white house as soon as next week we will
fight the woke in the legislature we
will fight the woke in Corporate America
we will never ever surrender to the woke
mob under DeSantis Florida has leaned
heavily into the culture wars just this
week the governor signed five bills
targeting lgbtq2 children and adults
we're not doing the pronoun Olympics in
Florida it's not happening here the feud
with Disney began after the state passed
its so-called don't say gay Bill
limiting discuss question of sexuality
in schools well when Disney spoke out
against that the governor and the
legislature just went ballistic soon
after DeSantis tried to end Disney's
long-standing self-governing status
Disney responded by suing alleging a
targeted campaign of government
harassment you know in the history of
American politics there have been many
efforts to punish corporations and
individuals for things they have said
that trouble whoever is in charge
it is seldom and done so in artfully and
so obviously for Disney to walk away
from a mega development now could signal
to voters desantis's policies are too
extreme for the mainstream there have
been a number of Republicans who might
run against him that are beginning to
highlight this and say this really is
anti-business and this is not
conservative but in the business of
Republican politics where DeSantis faces
a tough battle against former president
Donald Trump going toe-to-toe over
issues of inclusivity could be the Boost
that makes him the party's nominee
Jackson prosco Global News Washington
another big step announced today in
NASA's Artemis program the program that
will eventually see humans back on the
surface of the Moon NASA granted Jeff
bezos's company blue origin a 3.4
billion dollar U.S contract to develop a
lunar lander the craft will transport
four astronauts to the moon's surface
and is set to be used in the 2029
Artemis 5 Mission
[Music]
parking signs too confusing next in
Montreal there's an app for that
[Music]
we have artificial intelligence to help
drive cars but what about parking a
Quebec company released an app that uses
AI to help drivers decipher parking
rules in Montreal Mike Armstrong
explains how it works
it at times feels intentional as though
someone somewhere meant to make
Montreal's parking signs a boat as
complicated as possible the stars must
align Jupiter and Saturn what's the line
it's a little weird it's a little weird
problem tends to be overlap one pole and
multiple signs literally orders on top
of orders to be deciphered or else you
need to be very confident while people
behind you are honking and you're like
am I allowed am I taking a chance well
because parallel parking is hard enough
in fact too hard for some there is at
least help with the signage just click
the Read Sign it opens the camera a new
app is perhaps playfully named parking
we tested it in Old Montreal with the
developers take the picture it's
basically point and shoot but you do
have to tell it if you're parking before
or after the signage by Crossing out any
that don't apply and now these three
signs apply after the bowl so let's say
I'm gonna Park after the pole then
there's a little weight and an answer so
it tells you that no you cannot park and
it even tells you the reason which one
of the signs is not letting you park
developers had to train the AI to
understand the science it took more than
a thousand pictures to teach it what
overrides what depending on the day and
time so this is a good example right now
the app is kind of a one-off there
aren't any plans to expand to other
provinces it was yet another way to show
what can be done with AI
so our goal was to provide the answer
faster than the human would be able to
read and interpret the signs by himself
the idea for the app worth noting came
when a member of the team got a ticket
after being confused by a sign the chief
technology officer by the way fnap helps
with parking headaches maybe they could
consider tackling construction headaches
next
Global News Montreal
maybe you can go to other cities as well
that's global national for this Friday
I'm foreign Oster and tonight we're
saying farewell to a friendly face in
Victoria BC Winston has been greeting
guests at the historic Fairmont Empress
since 2019 and now he's headed onto
retirement and he was the perfect
Ambassador for the job because he got it
after failing guide dog training for
being too friendly enjoy retirement
Winston thanks for watching good night
thank you
[Music]